[Music]
really a much else to talk about oh do
you guys ever play breath of the wild
back in the day that was my segue I'm
almost a hundred hours into the game
would you you gave it a ten out of ten
gave it a ten out of ten I almost
punched everything yes Brown it's the
second ten I've ever given and I think
it II was the first one in the air solid
five shadow of Mordor yeah Metal Gear
Solid 5 which you seemed to like certain
kind of game a lot open-world merging
game plan you know it's weird I feel
like that's like kind of the thing I
review the most now because I somehow
like this is self-sacrifice my work but
you know it's weird like those two games
you can't really compare them but you
can't you kind of can't in a way and I
think it's because one of the things
that just makes Zelda so special and I
think is leading into what we're going
to talk about is just the the myriad
ways that you can tackle any situation
whether it's just simply movement or
it's like dealing with combat or puzzle
solving and mil Gear had a lot of that
as well but there are so many more rules
and options at play in Zelda even though
on the surface it looks like a far
simpler game right yeah Metal Gear
you're just scrolling through okay how
many weapons do I have like these
different vantage points like okay I'm
you know doesn't matter Zelda is is by
far the more complex game but it's
because you don't feel the weight of
that complexity then it's so nice and so
refreshing and innovative yes for me
certainly makes me think about how I'm
scoring games now differently yeah maybe
it's the art style or maybe it is the
sense of calm you get in some parts of
this Hyrule but it really does seem
simple as sometimes but then yet you see
stuff like this hitting a bee's nest to
drive these guys out so you can go get
their weapons so they can't pick them up
so you can attack them much easier those
bees are gonna chase you - yeah but I
have some fire get rid of them is that
how you get rid of I get rid of how cuz
there's no right way to play right
that's what I want to talk about today
is kind of how seemingly every single
person that is talking about this game
that I have talked to of like the 25
people is having a vastly different
experience right from the beginning you
start off on you know I don't know if
how that's the thing with this game
spoilers aren't really narrative
boilers I mean there are but this game
it's tough to talk about all the things
you're seeing because you don't want
some the best part is how you stumble
upon these things but I can't bring
myself to tweet about this game yeah I
feel like even showcasing a weapon that
someone hasn't found you know I find it
80 hours into the game I could have
found it a lot earlier but I don't know
when people are finding these things so
I don't want to rob anyone even of the
you know existence of certain things
it's and it's interesting how yeah again
like not linear it is you know the other
day I think you're not chatting like oh
did you go to Kakariko village but yes
okay well then you saw you must have
seen this along the way because there's
only one path to actually go right
however but you can I think it was it
was going to the Goron City you tell me
where the mines were that's when I was
like I I'm at the north mine you like oh
the south mine like that's not on my map
you mean the south mine and then you
it's on the main road right and then you
realize yeah you know the it's just like
the it's like an exponential factor
right like the more you play the more
you have just created your own path yeah
so you like you come to terms you're
like oh I must have paraglide it from
here and it's just there are so many
ways to get to said area and that's
where like the hours the early hours are
so different because I was you know rock
climbing a mountain because you know I
felt like rock climbing
well someone maybe wanted to hit a
shrine on the right side of the map like
it's that's the early aspect of it that
is just so different for everyone
yeah and one of the earlier things they
were talking about in this game is kind
of how it was following in the footsteps
of a link between worlds and that you
don't have to do dungeons in a set order
right there are four major dungeon this
in this game structurally speaking but
then they're also like how many shrines
are there 116 oh [ __ ] I think eight I'm
sorry yes game is huge I I've done 47
yeah yeah I went you know like right to
the zora the Linnea province province
right to do my first divine beast and
every time I go to sit down to play the
game I'm thinking I should there's a
shrine nearby I should do that or I
should go get this armor which a friend
told me was in this region or I should
do this but then I discovered something
new and it pulls me off the beaten path
and
but it's not overwhelming and I've it
takes a while to try to I couldn't put
my finger on it for a while why I love
it so much but this game you're
constantly thinking right I mean we
talked about how horizon zero dawn just
released and that's a great open-world
game but Zelda kind of like rewrites the
rules of what it means to be a good
open-world game right I go back to
horizon I'm actually kind of bored
moving between points I see an objective
marker and the world is gorgeous and I'm
moving through this jungle then it's a
desert and I'm fighting these really
cool robot dinosaurs but I'm not
thinking the entire time like I am in
Zelda Zelda you see you see a simple
tree and you're saying there could be
apples on that that would help me get
through this next book goblin camp it's
the mystery and once you and once you
have an event that happens to you in
this game where it is such a curve ball
blindside like I can't believe this
happened
that's when you oh you guys struck by
lightning cuz you have a massive
two-handed sword equipped that's that's
when you don't feel overwhelmed whelmed
but that's when you are getting
distracted because you see anything from
a person walking down the path - again
yeah a tree with a rock slightly to the
left like everything is so jam-packed
and thrilled in this world that you just
gotta do it because you also feel like
no one else has ever seen this yeah
you're inundated with possibilities and
it goes back to this idea that I've
probably said a thousand times to you
too but this lack of control you never
ever feel in control of the world you
never feel like you understand all of
its rules or all of its possibilities
which is part and parcel of it being
mysterious right and constantly having a
sense of wonder so yes even like a
simple mountain that you climb right
like it's you know the elevation brings
one thing the weather brings another
thing like what could be on top maybe
there's treasure right but oh what's
that in the distance once you get up
there like there are things that happen
like this and a lot of open-world games
including something like horizon which I
think is not a similar game but it's the
most recent you know thing we can
compare it to but this game just manages
to to never relent with just making you
wonder like what if and and in
comparison to horizon which again is an
awesome game - even Assassin's Creed
games with you know icons literally
littered on a map generally there is
a point where you know what you're gonna
get mm-hmm from this guy I don't need to
take on this beast because you know what
I know what he's packing so I'm just
gonna move on you're more inclined to
move on from different situations yeah
but this game I'm just constantly like
sticking through and then you die you
know I'm coming back yeah cuz now it's
like personal yeah oh I have a beef with
this one character that I ran into I
won't spoil it but could not I maybe if
I was much better at this game I mean
it's a difficult game but maybe I could
have beaten him but I'm coming back
later once I have more armor and whatnot
but these super viable mechanics and the
difficulty both I think are integral to
this world they are integral to this
world because the survival like you have
to the wilderness is just as much as an
enemy
this sounds cliche but Hyrule is an
enemy too but it can also like just
destroy you right it you can go into the
tundra and it's too cold and you don't
have warm enough clothes or you haven't
cooked something that can keep you warm
you know you can drown if you don't I
mean it's not until you go back to the
bank but I could kill you but if you run
that stamina you could fall off a cliff
take falling damage if it's raining the
broccoli too slick for you to climb up
you know the rain I feel lively is the
worst in the best possible way and it's
for me it's one of the first games I
think that like has actually brought the
meaning of rain yeah it's a full extent
opposed to any other game where it's
like oh it's raining things are a little
wet yeah this is like one it rains in
two completely [ __ ] completely masked
weirder damn I'm a good boy completely
messes with everything torches can have
a campfire you never cook you can't go
you can't you know Oh you think oh maybe
I can just wait out the rain or speed it
up with a campfire well it's raining
dude oh yeah you're on a cliff side and
it's raining and you slip and your
stamina is at zero and then there's a
river below you're dead I didn't like
lightning if you're wearing metal armor
get smell where you're carrying a metal
bow or a metal on you but also it's not
so systematic where it's like okay well
I know I have to wait five minutes
before the rain pass mm-hmm and you
think it's gone mm-hmm and then it comes
back and it's like 10 15 minutes of just
rain so we're getting yelled at for
spoiling the weather factors
it's what it's creepin popularized you
yes that's us but I think this is a
perfect example of how everything this
game is so freakin fascinating that even
what even the things that seems so basic
to us when we first found them you're
right when you first discovered it it's
like wow yeah it's hard to talk about
this game without really spoiling
because it's it's it's unprecedented I
think what it does another cool thing is
that you had played maybe 60 hours by
the time you review went up yeah and I
played half an hour and I saw some like
a mechanic that you didn't even know
about didn't ya Rob comes in the next
day he's like when did you find this is
like that's a thing you can do like I
just found out something new last night
again that whether it's a mechanic or
something related to survival or related
to something that I didn't even stumble
on because it was in this like cave that
I didn't go into when I was more focused
on going to Kakariko before I got pulled
off the beaten path to some other shrine
there's a lot in this game but none of
it feels like it's just there for the
sake of it it feels like it's well I
will counter your point I think the core
exceeds those are clearly there for the
sake of it like wow yeah on the top of a
mountain you know you're gonna find it's
like yeah that's the one thing to me
that feels a little bit like obvious and
contrived you know more than you know
anything else but it's because they're
just simply everywhere they're just
simply everywhere and every time you see
something you're like okay well I know
the developer like made this so that I
would find this thing like it's it's
it's super clear what it is it doesn't
harm the game it's just that one thing
where I was like I wonder if that could
have been different but yeah Carroll
mm-hmm yeah cuz it yeah I don't I don't
want to put what those do but like yeah
you that is the one thing that seems
like there's something there just to say
oh this is we can fill up this gap in
the map with one of these or something I
don't know it's a small way to reward
like a modest achievement right I know
it's luckily it's quick enough you know
what I mean yeah it was it's sometimes
they're opposing I guess occasionally
there's some there maybe longer but for
the most part you they're simple enough
to just like easily knock out in like 10
seconds hit and quit yeah dude just like
rid right yeah like before I got in here
talking with Tay and that guy is only
put in what six hours and he told me
something
that just blew my mind yeah blew my mind
I was like how did you see this was it
the skeleton thing yeah it's um well
someone last night was saying something
- yeah there's a lot in this game I it's
it never feels overwhelming which is
weird because a lot of times open-world
games even with horizon which there's
not like you know I don't want to just
say a Zelda's great because there's so
much to do like I think we've already
touched on why I think it's all integral
for the most part but horizon I got
overwhelming for some reason there's not
like half of things to do in that game
and find out but like there's always
something mechanic in Zelda that
encourages you for not just exploring
the world itself but exploring how the
game works
and connects you to that world whether
it's through the survival or the
difficulty that everything seems and I'm
talking to people in this game more than
I have in any other game in a long time
because they have these like this dad
will be telling a ghost story to keep
kids away from this certain spot or this
person will say oh yeah I saw something
up there and I'll read this ruin that
said oh there's there's this hidden
artifact up there that people will use
to talk about but now it's like flooded
so you can't get there and it won't tell
you where it is it'll say where it is
but it won't like put a objective point
on your map up to you to put the
objective point through your she could
slate scope or or at best look at your
map and be like okay the guy was talking
about a body of water what bodies of
water are around here yeah crap there's
a bunch that's ones are gonna be and
then you get there and then you discover
something else and just like it's got a
sense of geography and moving through it
that I haven't felt in an open-world
game in a long time I mean you look at
Grand Theft Auto 5 what you think he's
one of the better open-world games and
that makes it feel like a real world
that's lived in that you can explore but
still there would be like 10 minute
periods I'm just driving across Los
Santos and I'm turning my brain off and
Zelda because of a survival or because
of the fact that there's probably
something pretty cool around the corner
I never stopped thinking and I've never
disengaged and I say never because I've
played 25 hours at this point and I
still haven't gotten bored you played a
hundred and you're still not bored not
even close to bored and I the fact alone
that I have over I'm not even halfway
done with the shrines and I look at my
map and I'm like I have never explored
this huge area yeah and there's a few of
those like I'm so happy to have a game
that I already love and know that I
continue to love for the next few weeks
yeah once I have to cut us off because I
feel like we could just talk about this
forever we'll probably find we have a
ton of zel I mean oh did you want to add
anything that we didn't say I might know
you do but I love you know for a game
obviously doesn't it's not like texture
heavy or intense it feels like all that
was put into like just the breathing
nature and animations of like a book
hobbling camp like my favorite things
always say is like you do I just love
like looking at them and it's like you
know I think we've tired this like
comment but it's like you know six of
them and there's just one guys on a
story and everyone's like yeah totally
yeah and then one of them will just art
dancing and he's like yeah dance party
and it's like I'm throwing a bomb in
like I just you know wildlife like just
it just feels so freakin good just like
watch and observe take photos I never
thought like well the first time they
like showed like you know linked like
doing photos and selfies and stuff it
just feels so right the charm the charm
fits and I loved God like I filled up
the album I was like out Greg I believe
some of my favorites but you get to keep
them if they're added to the compendium
yeah so you can go back there yeah but
it's not pretty photos right yeah man I
want to play this right now yeah so well
cut it off there but I I would invite
you to share your Zelda stories in the
comments but obviously like try not to
spoil anything but like her stop if you
want to Twitter and let us know like
spoil a thing it's such a weird game I
made the mistake of using Google to look
up one thing yesterday for the first
time and I immediately regretted it yeah
it's it kind of sucked it was it
actually was the exact thing that I
expected that would happen from the
thing I was looking up but to just even
have that confirmed was like damn it I
just robbed it myself of this like don't
do it don't do it this is just so hard
to talk about game now it's so great all
right well so that is the end of that
segment and getting closely out of our
show but let us know what you think
about sell that breath of the wild how
are you playing it what are some of the
what are some of direction do you took
when you left the early part of the game
let us know without spoiling too much
leaving the comments but again try not
to pull too much but yeah let us know
you think about breath of the wild Pete
gave it a 10 out of 10 on GameSpot we
have a ton of coverage up we have guides
if you're into that if you don't want to
discover certain things for yourself or
if you just want some things kind of
more illuminated for you we have some
helpful guides up from a bunch of our
editors we also have something starting
tomorrow that you two are excited about
Pete and Rob you'll be it's called the
Triforce and I had Pete described
earlier Rob what you guys gonna be doing
oh your talk about it yeah every
Thursday right that's when I may have
jury duty tomorrow show yeah we're gonna
we're gonna play the game and we're
gonna add factors and difficulties for
instance you know maybe we'll play naked
because apparently us both yes oh yeah
of course and Linc but we're gonna play
the game differently and you know
throughout each episode we're gonna you
know spend a little time with physics
maybe we'll go snowboarding but the plan
is by the end of each episode we're
gonna make a run at Ganon with the rules
that we've set the rules we set and it's
gonna be fairly early game for the most
we're not gonna spoil anything but we're
definitely gonna have enough like
equipment to give us enough variables to
choose from yeah is this gonna be a live
stream and then archived or is it all
yeah pre-recorded okay cool
and then there's what time planned
tomorrow today's Thursdays 10:30 a.m.
10:30 a.m. Pacific time that's right so
watching another specifically
pacifically time for those watching in a
different region I'm really excited for
that yeah Pete you know one thing that I
don't think breath of the wild does you
can't become a painting and warp on two
walls like you can in a link between
worlds Canyon you mean like this like
there we go there's the original
I forgot about it didn't you can you do
that and blood breath of the wild I
don't think so wow you did it that many
times you gave that game a 10 out of 10
when you can't even do this Gidi wall
walk thing did I fall asleep at my house
watching this sometimes yeah I love that
like really I love that look at the end
where your face is still doing it but
your body's not right you look slightly
uncomfortable but okay oh I think
they're just looping it now oh yeah
there it is your face just stayed in it
your face was still painting on the wall
all right I would say enough of that but
there's never enough good news that in
the intro for the show I think just make
a lobby intro that all right everybody
yeah
so let us know we think of breath of a
wild the Triforce starts tomorrow we are
streaming overwatch at 1:00 today for a
National Women's Day chastity and she
will be playing overwatch playing is all
the women characters a lot of which in
that game are badass my favorite
character Anna she's pretty sweet I
would say swear more but Pete's giving
me the stern eye again look at that
giveaway I'm gonna have Rob on all these
quick if you here we have a pixel pals
Luigi and then we have toad and Peach
amiibo if you want to retweet
GameSpot's tweet shiva did put in the
chat earlier but if you don't just go to
GameSpot's twitter account follow
gamespot if you don't already retweet it
and later in the week we will pick a
winner and you could receive these as
part of our we have this like nick
margarita a memorial library of limited
edition toys and games and whatnot so
we're kind of just trying to empty it
out by giving it to our fans so yeah
later in the week hopefully you will be
a winner May Nick rest in peace yes you
said Nick Memorial Library Nick
margarita Memorial Library as we call
our vault this amazing resin yes may he
rest in peace
anybody thanks again for joining stream
at 1:00 p.m. so stick around
the Triforce starts tomorrow Sunday next
episode of reboot show Jake Decker and I
work on it's kind of like it's inspired
by Daniels where's the point when he
left we want to do an opinion editorial
show I talk a lot about breath of a wild
it's pretty much about breath of the
wild
I just wanted to pimp that it won't talk
too much more about it but that'll be
Sunday at 3:00 p.m. yeah check that out
if you want to kind of look at breath
the well
even deeper thanks more spoilers on it
no good it's yeah it's we made sure to
keep that spoiler free so if you haven't
played or if you're playing a hundred
hours and don't still don't want
something spoiled then still feel free
to stop by and watch that anyway
everybody thanks so much for joining and
we will see you next week on the lobby
[Music]